they are co-defendants at the center of
allegations they conspire to hack phones
and bribe public officials at the time
these pictures were taken in 2000
rebecca brooks and andy coulson were two
years into a secret love affair a
relationship which would last till at
least two thousand four
prosecutors revealed those details not
they say to intrude but to demonstrate
how close rebecca brooks and andy and
where and how much they trusted each
other
the jury was shown the draft of a letter
found on mrs brooks computer dating back
to february 2004
and an apparent response to mr coulson's
desire to end the affair
it read the fact is you are my very best
friend i tell you everything i confide
in you i seek your advice i love you
care about you worry about you we laugh
and cry together in fact without our
relationship in my life i'm not sure i
will cope
prosecutors say when that letter was
drafted andy coulson and rebecca brooks
had been having an affair dating back to
1998 and spanning the period covered by
the phone hacking conspiracy charge
crown council andrew edis said when
people are charged with conspiracy the
first thing that a jury has to answer is
how well did they know each other how
much did they trust each other
mr rita said the fact that they were in
this relationship which was a secret
means that they trusted each other quite
a lot with at least that secret and
that's why we're telling you about it
the crown claims that under rebecca
brooks and andy coulson stewardship
phone hacking was commonplace at the
news of the world
two of the most senior figures in the
last labour government were its alleged
victims of this practice
in april 2006 tessa jowell then the
olympics minister hit the headlines over
bribery allegations involving her
husband
prosecutors say her mobile phone
voicemails were hacked by this man
former news of the world private
investigator glenn mulcair
the jury was shown an email sent by mr
mulcair which the prosecution claims
outlined some of the information he
found on tessa giles voicemail it read
substantial traffic both ways also looks
like she's selling up
the special adviser to lord prescott
also had her voicemails intercepted by
mulcair it's claimed as the tabloid
looked for information of an affair the
politician had had with his secretary
all eight defendants in this case denied
the charges against them the
prosecution's opening argument will
continue on friday
mark white sky news at the old bailey